should we speak before ready well the
answer is you're never ready We are
Never As Good in the language as we
would like to be if the objective is to
perform well but if the objective is to
communicate like I'm in a situation is
going to be in Polish we have to
communicate I communicate I grab
whatever I have whatever I can remember
of Polish whatever comes to my mind
that's in a Slavic language I throw in
the odd English word and we communicate
and what I hear is pure relevant High
resonance content so that it's a very
good experience so I think in language
learning we are never quite as good as
we would like to be and yet we still
have to go there and use the language
should we speak before ready yes because
we're never really ready but we should
nevertheless try to prepare as much as
we can focusing on our input activities
so speak when you feel like it